In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinek Sadion from A3rd, on which we commemorate, the Holy Martyrs
Timothy and Mauta, St. Timothy came from a village near Thebes in Egypt.
He was ordained reader, and through the reading of the lives of the saints, during church
services, he confirmed the Christians in their hope of good things to come.
When Diocletians first edicts against the Christians were published in 304, only 20 days after his
marriage to the devout Mauta, Timothy was denounced as an ardent preacher of the new religion
and taken before Aryan, the prefect of Thebes, who called on him to hand over the service
books.
But the saint refused, saying, as a father could not possibly willingly give his children
over to death, in the same way I would die rather than give over these books, by which
the faithful and I myself receive the grace of God and the protection of his angels to
be burned.
Beside himself with fury, Aryan had red-hot spikes thrust into his ears, piercing the
eardrum, and gouged out his eyes.
They both falling to the ground.
They then tied him to a nail-covered wheel and flayed his skin, but Timothy was healed
by the grace of God and held out against the other tortures, crying out that nothing could
separate him from the love of Christ.
The tyrant then had him thrown in prison and summoned Mauta with the hope of using her
to overcome Timothy's resistance.
He tried at first, through flattery, to induce her to bring her husband to reason so that she
would not lose him after only twenty days of marriage.
After a short walk with Timothy, Mauta left the prison filled with a holy ardor and confessed
to the prefect that she also was a Christian and was ready to give her life for Christ.
Aryan had her hair shorn, and after having had her fingers cut off, she was thrown into boiling
water.
She, however, remained untouched, and said to the magistrate, your fire is a poor one.
If you haven't got enough wood, send servants to my parents' house, and they will give you
some.
Aryan went up to her, wanting to verify if the water was hot enough.
Mauta, through some of it at him, and yelling with pain the prefect saw the skin of his hand
peeling off with the scalding.
He then ordered that the saint be burned with torches primed with pitch and sulfur.
But Mauta still remained untouched, and mocked the powerlessness of her persecutors.
Aryan then ordered that the couple be tied to crosses facing each other, and left to die slowly.
They remained thus crucified in imitation of our Lord Jesus Christ for nine whole days,
sustaining each other in patience.
Filled with rage at the spectacle of the victory of Christ who dwelt within them through faith,
the devil took human form and gave Mauta a cup of milk mixed with honey in order to refresh
her, but the saint repulsed him with her prayer.
He then carried her in imagination to a land of delights with the river of milk flowing nearby.
She armed herself with a holy anger in order to reject once again these deceptive advances,
and declared that she preferred to drink the cup of eternal life that Christ presented to
her on the cross.
As soon as the demon departed, an angel of the Lord appeared.
Took Mauta by the hand, and, leading her in a vision to heaven, showed her a resplendent
throne on which there lay a brightly shining robe and a golden crown, and he said to her,
it is for you that these things are prepared.
He then took her to a still higher place where there was another throne, another white robe,
and another crown, and added, these are prepared for your husband, as it was he who was the
cause of your salvation.
Come to herself once more, Mauta told Timothy of this revelation, and it was with joy that
they together confided their souls into God's keeping on the tenth day.
Devout Christians bought their bodies with silver and buried them with honor, giving thanks
to God for having glorified His holy martyrs.
Many healings were later wrought, not only over their relics, but also for the faithful
who venerated their icon or called on the names of the Holy Spouses.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.